REFEREES ARE BRANDON
THE YEAR AND THE JETS HAVE THE
HANDLING THROUGH RAIN DROP,  AW
HEART BEAT, TO THE BACK OF THE
TWICE.
PIERRE-LUC DUBOIS BEING REUNITED
WITH NIKOLAJ EHLERS AND
NET, AND THE JETS IN THIS
SHIFT VESALAINEN HASN'T SCORED E
HIS FIRST GAME OF THE YEAR PUTSG
SAVE.AME LOSE, AND HUGHES GETS
THE DEVILS TONET.
HUGHES WITH HISLS GETS
ONE LATE IN THE FIRST, ONE EARLY
IN THE SECOND, THAN GAM THISAME
AND THE DEVILS HAVE COME FROM
3-0 FOR A OALS IN
THE LAST FEW.
GRAV LOWRY A LINE, LEAVES FOR
ZACHA, OFF THES SECOND OF THE G
KNOTTED WAY.
HUNGER
CORECOVERY, D TO Ds, WE HAVE
A B AWAY FROM HIM,
PUCK IN FRONT OF OF THEY IN
FRONT AND SLI
OFF THE ARM OF SIEGENTHALER,
LOOK GOAL OFF
THE RUSH!ITH TWO.
WATCH THE WAY HE TOE DRA
GOOD SAVE.
MACKENZIE BLACKWOOD PICKED THAT
UP LATE AND MADE A GOOD REACTION
TRICK, AND THE JETSERE,
DOES HE?
HE LETS THE BOMB GO ON THE ONE
THE LINE, IT WAS SEVEN, IT WAS
BLUE.